le bureau du président des états-unis
il est temps de drainer le marécage que
nous allons livrer nous allons
avoir les meilleures personnes du monde cette
histoire de russie avec atout et la russie est une histoire inventée
il n'y a absolument pas  collusion qui
a été prouvée
ils pensent que c'est la russie le président poutine
il vient de dire que ce n'est pas la russie
nous allons construire un grand mur ils
apportent le crime
ils sont des violeurs et le mexique paiera
pour le mur je suis un génie très stable
personne n'est plus fort que moi
je suis la personne la moins raciste dans cette salle personne n'a été plus dur avec la russie que moi il n'y a personne de plus grand ou meilleur dans l'armée que moi personne n'aime la
bible plus que moi personne ne savait
que les soins de santé pourraient être si compliqués
mon administration a accompli plus
que
presque n'importe quelle administration dans l'histoire
de notre pays,
je pourrais me tenir au milieu de la cinquième
avenue et tirer sur quelqu'un et je ne
perdrais aucun électeur d'accord,
il y avait du sang qui coulait de ses yeux à
propos de euh blood co  sortir d'elle
partout où j'ai le droit de faire
ce que je veux en tant que président je pense que
c'est un général très surestimé
vous ne donnez jamais de déclaration de revenus lorsque vous
êtes audité je suis un
écologiste beaucoup de gens ne le comprennent pas
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'il y a de la faute des deux côtés lorsque
vous rapportez de fausses nouvelles ce que cnn
fait beaucoup vous êtes l'ennemi des gens
votre organisation est terrible vous êtes une
personne très
impolie j'étais vraiment dur et lui aussi
et nous allons  faire des allers-retours
et puis nous sommes tombés amoureux mon appel était
parfait
hier le président de l'ukraine a dit
qu'il n'y avait aucune pression sur
lui merci beaucoup c'est
un grand honneur merci beaucoup
covent covent covent le
4 novembre tu vas '  Je n'entends rien à ce sujet
c'est leur nouveau canular
et puis je vois le désinfectant où il l'
assomme
en une minute d'injection à l'intérieur il
va disparaître un jour c'est comme un miracle
convoiter une pandémie secrète que les
gens n'achètent pas à cnn espèce d'idiot
Les gens sont fatigués d'entendre
fouchy et tous ces idiots, nous rendrons l'
Amérique encore plus belle,
reculez et restez là, je cours
contre le pire de l'histoire de la
présidentielle et maintenant, si je perds, pouvez-vous
imaginer que c'est une fraude majeure dans notre
pays
Franchement, nous avons gagné cette élection, nous
ne concéderons jamais que
cela n'arrive pas, vous ne
concédez pas quand il y a du vol.